ce document contient les 28 mesures
mises en place par le gouvernement pour
améliorer la santé des détenus dans
cette maison d'arrêt de bois d'arcy les
personnes incarcérées ont accès à une
unité hospitalière ou encore un centre
de lutte contre les addictions
on rencontre beaucoup de gens pour qui
il n'y a pas de ya pas beaucoup de
contacts avec le monde de la santé à
l'extérieur on a une population assez
jeunes sur bois d'arcy également et puis
on a des patients qui sont qui sont très
vulnérables qui sont dans des situations
sociales compliqué à l'extérieur et qui
ont un mauvais accès aux soins scie à
bois d'arcy les structures médicales
sont adaptés pour prendre en charge les
détenus ce n'est pas le cas partout
d'où cette feuille de route qui s'étend
jusqu'en 2020 2 qui a plusieurs
objectifs
c'est permettre d'avoir un bilan je
pense notamment aux jeunes qui sont sous
protection judiciaire lié à la jeunesse
avec une facilité un bilan de santé
dès qu'ils sont en détention c'est aussi
de la prévention par rapport au suicide
la formation auprès des professionnels
pénitentiaire mais aussi professionnels
de santé prévenir aussi en termes de
dépendance est liée au handicap
favorisons la détection des personnes
détenues qui ont ces difficultés là
autre mesure annoncée le développement
de la télémédecine ou encore la mise en
place de stages en milieu pénitentiaire
pour les internes en médecine la
réinsertion des détenus est également
concernée c'est aussi notre volonté de
travailler sur la continuité du parcours
de soins après la sortie de la détention
c'est un défi majeur tout notre enjeu
c'est de faire le lien entre ce qui se
passe dans la détention et en dehors de
la détention
je crois que c'est un enjeu capital pour
éviter la récidive
il est également prévu d étude nationale
sur la santé mentale des personnes
détenues
le dernier état des lieux date d'il ya
15 ans